hello this is uh steve kaufman here um
i uh steve kaufman the founder of link
and uh
over at my blog the linguist on language
i've had a very
interesting exchange
it began with an interview that i
posted as a podcast an interview with
benny the irish polyglot
and that generated more back and forth
than just about anything i've ever done
on my blog so there was a lot of
interest
and i think there was interest because
benny and i while we agree on many
things we do disagree on certain things
with regard to language learning
benny the irish polyglot and you can see
references on my blog and you can go to
his blog to learn more about
what he does
but he is someone who is very much
committed to
traveling the world to
you know live two or three months in
different countries and his view is that
the best way to learn a language is to
go to the country for two months or
three months after which
you can learn you can achieve what he
calls you can speak the language
pretty well he says
not very clear he doesn't really define
what pretty well is all you can ask him
and he claims that that
somehow this method is uniquely
effective
that other methods and he particularly
seems not to appreciate an input-based
approach to learning
which he occasionally calls not human
um
so
you know and we had lots of exchange on
this thing so i'd like to talk a bit
more about it
and it's also of course having had that
exchange gives me an opportunity to
think about
different approaches to language
learning and so i i kind of want to
get at what i think is is
my view on all of this
uh after having that had that exchange
uh i i firmly believe and the more i
think about it i think the words of
wisdom from that lady whose name i can't
remember
at the university of san diego who said
there are three things in language
learning the attitude of the learner
the time you have with the language
and your ability to notice what's
happening in the language those are the
three big factors no matter how often i
talk about language learning up and down
and i push link and benny pushes his
system and somebody else pushes someone
other some other system some people like
rosetta stone
he still boils down to those three
elements your attitude the time
and your ability to notice or things
that you can do that can help you notice
so
obviously i think benny and i agree on
attitude you've got to be positive you
got to feel you can do it
um where we disagree is how you should
spend your time
and this is where he comes this issue of
speaking
he believes that from the first day that
you start into a language or as soon as
possible you should get yourself over to
where they speak that language and start
speaking it
my view is that whether you do that or
not doesn't matter
i'm not saying that it's a an
ineffective way
i think as katie on on one of her
comments to my to the discussion said
people have been learning languages that
way for thousands of years sure they
have but when they speak when you speak
to someone
in a different language
even at the very early and particularly
at the early stages mostly you're
listening
and so i remain convinced particularly
after after having heard
uh benny and also having had a chat with
megan who's another learner she has a
slightly different approach he has the
radio going in the background all the
time
that listening is the key
and i would add that i think reading is
a form of listening
because when you are learning a language
until you get very good in the language
when you read your vocalizing
so you are you are connecting to the
sounds of the language you may be
vocalizing them slightly incorrectly but
but but the writing is in a way a
recording
of
something that would otherwise have been
said because speech begins with speaking
and therefore with listening and until
they had
tape recorders or
uh you know mp3 players
we recorded things by writing it down so
it is also a record a recording of
speech it's a form of listening you have
to get the language in you and if you
are so inclined or if you happen to live
in the country where the language is
spoken and if you have friends that
tolerate you coming along and
occasionally bumbling something in their
language
um then by all means speak but the main
activity is listening and i went back to
my book and my experiences in japan
where i did a lot of listening to tapes
and reading but i had a person by the
name of nick yazaki who was my assistant
at the canadian embassy
and he was just extremely patient and
extremely friendly and he was extremely
long-winded and so if i said something
to him i got 10 minutes back of
explanations and that again was
listening
so
and i know that in japan and in many
places people like to say i just like to
talk if you know in japan and talk about
you know ego kaiwa they want to have
conversations and somehow they're going
to learn through their conversations you
will
if you hear a lot of native speakers
speaking in my view i think that the
benefit of listening to non-native
speakers speak the language is minimal
and that's why i think that classrooms
i mean if i as i've said in one of my
previous posts if i had a classroom i
would let the kids read and listen on
their ipods rather than having to listen
to each other or even to speak to each
other because the actual act of speaking
itself doesn't bring the language into
you and as i have said before
the obviously the goal and benny likes
to suggest that my goal is just to read
well no my goal is to speak
and i speak if i say i speak a language
it's because i speak it i may not speak
portuguese very well i may not speak
russian very well but my goal is to
speak and i like to speak it but i like
to speak a lot more now that i have had
my input and the better off you get the
further along you get in the language
the more you're likely to speak and the
more you're likely to enjoy your
speaking
uh but to the idea that you're going to
speak your way to fluency i don't
believe i think that's the speaking the
what benny does and what others do who
like to speak right away and my wife is
that way she wants to speak right away
she's not going to listen to an ipod
but what it does is trigger
the native speaker then to speak
and so then you are able to listen again
because it's the listening that brings
it in and as i've said before when you
speak and you stumble and struggle then
it also helps you notice and that was
the third issue was noticing but there
are many things that can help you notice
if you write you notice that you haven't
got the words if you speak you notice
that you haven't got the words if you
have your writing corrected you notice
where the mistakes are if you review
words in anki you that helps your brain
to notice if you look at texts in uh
link that where the words you have
looked up are highlighted in yellow that
helps you notice so everything boils
down to obviously the attitude to begin
with and i agree with many we shouldn't
be timid but on the other hand we
shouldn't force ourselves to speak too
early and i as i said in my interview if
i were going to go to a country like say
russia
you know i
want to wait until i'm good
and then i go to russia and i can really
enjoy meeting up with people and
speaking to them on a variety of
subjects and finding out about russia
and finding out about their lives and so
forth to go there and stumble when i
have no words for three months i don't
believe uh i don't believe that that's a
good that's a good approach at least
it's not for me and i think we have to
be very careful in all of this that we
don't write off somebody else's approach
uh you know benny calls my approach
inefficient inhuman i don't know
whatever
no
it's not what he likes to do uh what he
does is not something that i would like
to do and i give reasons for it
uh but i know there are people who don't
have the patience
to listen and initially you have to
listen often to the same stuff
and initially you're reading
uninteresting stuff
because
you haven't got the ability you don't
have enough words to read anything more
interesting so some people don't want to
do that they want to start talking and
that's fine
the important thing for those people
though is that they continue to to want
to improve and that they continue to try
to notice what's happening in the
language otherwise they will develop a
sort of defensive level in the language
which enables them to say a few things
with the limited vocabulary and they
never push themselves beyond that point
and we have many many examples of
immigrants here and in other countries
who achieve that level and is then
called at the you know that their level
is fossilized
i prefer if people are genuinely motiva
motivated to improve that they avail
themselves that they spend a lot of that
time that second element time and they
spend it on a lot of listening and
reading
listening
if they don't like the to some
impersonal nature of uh listening to
exciting interviews on the on the ipod
which i love to do but some people don't
like to do that go find and engage
people in conversation but the main
thing you'll be doing is listening and
listening hopefully to native speakers
so what i wanted to say is kind of just
some and go if you're interested go to
the blog there's 55 comments on this
thing
uh
i say you can't speak your way to
fluency you have to get it in you and
you have to spend a lot of time
listening and if you don't like to read
that's too bad because reading is also
very very effective and it is human
because humans write and humans read
so there you have it thank you for
listening bye for now